I see cycling is very much part of our
future journeys to work and for leisure
as well but in particular here at team
bridge the idea that it might be quicker
to get to work across town on a bicycle
Devon Newton as well notorious for being
a little bit hilly and none of us want
to arrive at work all sweaty and having
just tried this bike I I'm absolutely
amazed at how much it does help you and
I'm certainly converted and so you can
arrive at work fresh
yeah I mean there's more and more cycle
routes out there now and so you're able
to stay off the road and certainly
people who've already use this electric
bike are saying that because it enables
them to keep up with the speed of the
traffic around them they actually feel
far more confident so whereas previously
they might not have considered cycling
actually they're feeling more confident
to even get out there and mingle with
the traffic a bit I regularly cycle
across Newton ever and really have very
little trouble in terms of danger so I
do encourage people just to try it you
know start walking quieter roads and
then and then build up